citizens of reject Nation I am here to bring
you a video I don't think I've seen before I
want to break down the most accurate comic
book movies which implies both reading the
comics and watching the movie now some of these I
haven't seen in a while but from memory these are
I think the 10 most accurate comic book movies
please do like subscribe hit that Bell if you
want to see more videos like this I'm trying to
convince Greg to let me do a best of comic book
movies video and we're between 10 25 and 100.
I'm trying to let them do 100 it's not gonna
let me do 100 but we're trying to convince
him to go up to 50. so check that video out
leave a comment telling Greg you want to see a
top 50 comic book movie video and pump me down
on Tick Tock where I do 30 second 15 second one
minute three minute short form videos breaking
news and breaking down all sorts of comic goodness
let's get into the most accurate comic book films
foreign number 10 a very accurate representation
of the character and a very accurate
representation of the stories around the storyline
but not a direct adaptation of one comic through
line making this kind of a tricky thing but I've
got Batman Begins Batman Begins is a very good
after adaptation of year one it's a very good
adaptation of young Bruce Wayne which has been
told in so many different storylines and it's a
very accurate Bruce Wayne but in the comic books
there isn't a Razzle ghoul switch there isn't uh
there's more ducares there's more certain things
but to me this established Gotham this established
the loss of his family this established all that
year one this established the tone the closest
to most of the Batman mythology that I'd ever
seen and I consider this one of the most accurate
comic adaptations because it gets who Bruce and
Batman are very early and very quickly this is
300 uh number nine is 300. that movie changed a
lot of things and doesn't get enough credit Zack
Snyder made a movie that was almost a storyboard
use of the comic book like that is a frame
for frame Recreation he really played with
the palette he played with the edit he played
with the sound design he did a lot of things
to put you in the world of 300 Frank Miller who
wrote and Illustrated 300 was also very Hands-On
they collaborated and it shows Frank Miller
and Zack Snyder I think are the duo that goes
like Hey we're gonna do this thing that's gonna be
adapting but also translating but it's gonna work
and I don't think a lot of other Duos have really
done that and I will say I think Zack Snyder when
you want something translated by way of putting
it into another medium he's the guy because he's
three of these on this list next up at number
eight we have dread the newest iteration of
dread yes the Stallone one's a fun time but the
newest dread is the comic book Carl Irvin looks
like he was ripped right out of that page I loved
that with Olivia Thirlby as like the new recruit
I love that it felt like we were living in the
comic sometimes feels like a video game and the
movie felt more like a video game adaptation than
a lot of video game adaptations because that's
what the comic felt like a lot of the time I love
the use of slow-mo I love the editing thing that
made it feel like you were going into a comic
book frame I love the pacing that made it feel
like certain action set pieces were Pages flipping
this all very very clearly becomes the comic book
flavor you want out of something that's so pulp
no worry like Dread and Carl Urban absolutely
nailed it love this movie my number is 2004's
Hellboy now this movie kind of proved that this
is the way to do it when 2019's Hellboy was a
direct translation what's important in making
comic book movies is making sure it's a comic book
movie which needs to be both an adaptation and a
translation which is why for example Civil War is
not much like the comic book but it works in the
medium of film Hellboy the original showed what
you need to gather the tone to get the world to
make the bprd work to get all the the underground
paranoia the world of Monsters the Guillermo del
Toro of it all versus trying to make a frame by
frame comparison which is what they did in the
2019 Hellboy ironically what works for Zack Snyder
and Frank Miller team up or Zack Snyder working
off you know Alan Moore's work is he makes the
medium of film through the comic book Lens whereas
I feel like when you're trying to translate too
directly it's trying to film a frame of comic book
and there's a big difference Hellboy the original
is a pitch perfect example of how you capture a
world how you grow out a world and you make it fit
in your medium using your skill set if you cast
correctly and you have the most incredible team
of special effects artists assembled love o Force
Hellboy number six remember remember the fifth of
November I think V for Vendetta the graphic novel
is one of the most important and I think the movie
is also one of the movies that established that
comic book movies aren't just for kids and I think
that's a really important distinction the adult
maturity intellectualism and and progress that V
for Vendetta made cannot be shortchanged like the
wachowskis produced this film and they used a lot
of their incredible sensibilities to make this a
giant spectacle and the trailers very much leaned
into the Hugo weaving of it all and the incredible
knife play and Natalie Portman but if you look
at the actual movie it's talking about very real
very adult things it's talking about overthrowing
a government it's talking about fascism it's talk
betting and dictator state so it's able to do what
comic books do well which is be action-packed have
interesting characters and yes [__] Bros on the
internet be political comic books are inherently
political V for Vendetta does an incredible job
being political being intelligent showing its
perspective but also being action-packed enough
and in this case following the comic enough
that is one one of the most direct incredible
adaptations one of the most accurate adaptations
of any book to screen number five we are back to
the world of Zack Snyder and this one is tricky
and this one is probably gonna get me some comic
book Kickback because this one is very accurate
for 95 of the time that last five percent is
a huge change that is Watchmen Watchmen change
the ending of the most important graphic novel of
all time but it did to make it work for the medium
and I would not change that I love that the show
that just came out on HBO Max that's long form
went back to the original ending and was able to
because it's adapting the book it's not adapting
this movie it's adapting where the book left off
but since it had long form it was able to explain
the squids it was able to live in that world what
I love about what Zack Snyder did with Watchman
is I felt like I was living the comic book and
then I got to be surprised but it still had the
emotional resonance it still had the impact it
still had the ending it still did what the book
did but it adapted it it evolved it for the medium
I'm not saying of all isn't better I'm saying it
it turned it into the medium of filmmaking now
it was perfectly cast the special effects still
hold up and it looks incredible they use the comic
books basically as a framework it grabbed frames
and somehow translated them to scream and it did a
really cool thing with sound design and music like
Smashing Pumpkins songs to this day makes me think
of Watchmen because it was so that world and it
was so paranoid and it was so about what happens
when the world goes wrong and it makes me feel
like who watches the Watchmen it makes me feel
like that sense of dread and I think this movie
is incredible and I think the ending change
Works which is why it makes my most accurate
adaptations list because it is accurate to the
comics in how it changed number four is a weird
tie because I don't know how to count we got two
movies one of them is getting this love because it
is an incredible adaptation of the energy of the
comic and also uses the frame so that is one way
I see adaptation work and that is Scott Pilgrim
versus the world Scott Pilgrim versus the world
feels exactly like the comic the other one tied at
number four is a very different movie out together
but just as colorful and that is Spider-Man into
the spider-verse the reason I'm picking Spider-Man
into the spider-verse is it adapts the characters
so incredibly well while not following the comic
book storyline it is accurate to Peter Parker is
it is accurate who spidergwen is it is accurate to
Miles Morales is it brings us Miles Morales and it
does so while explaining quantum theory and giving
us 10 other Spider-Man while never sacrificing
who miles is while giving us a miles origin story
so what's interesting to me about into the
spider-verse is it's incredibly accurate to
miles but it's not the spider verse Story in the
comics there's no more Lin there's no uh Spider
totems all that might come into play and across
the spider-verse but I doubt it all of those
things are so accurate to the comic books and it
is the most accurate for me of the animated films
because it literally feels like you're turning
the page of a comic book The Animation style
all of those elements make these both some of the
most accurate visual translations of a comic book
I've ever seen and they're both very special for
changing the game the cacophony of Edgar Scott
Pilgrim cannot be like denied like what it did
to change editing and all those things and the
visual aesthetic and editing and stylistic choices
across the spider into the spider-verse are going
to resonate through animation for the rest of time
and it feels just like a comic so these two tied
at number four I'm making the list I can make my
own when this movie came out it was everywhere
and does not get the love it used to and it should
and I think that's because the sequel kick ass one
is the comic book with big daddy Nick Cage you
change what the comic book was because now you
hear Nick Cage when you read it because they were
so accurate to what that book was it played with
the Beats it played with the friendship it found
sets that looked just like John meter Jr drawings
it went frame by frame but what it did was it let
the edit of the movie not make it feel like it was
too beholden to the comic book so it's accurate
to the comic book and it uses the elements it uses
the pacing but it's not trapped in any sort of way
this is Johnny Jr is one of my favorite artists of
all time this is the closest we will ever see to
the very iconic genre meter Junior Splash Pages
his framing his choices I think the casting is
second to none when you look back at Chloe Grace
Moretz as hit girl that was all anyone was talking
about that entire summer when you look at what we
first got the introduction of Adrian Taylor
Johnson as Kick-Ass and that's not to mention
again the Batman Adam West take that Nicholas
Cage did as Big Daddy I think it elevated the
comic book the comic was already exceptional the
movie made it even better because of how accurate
it was to the comic book that when you read the
comic back it changes your whole experience and
I think this movie uh doesn't get enough love in
the modern conversation alright this one is very
interesting in assessing it because this one does
not follow any direct comic book storyline but it
changed the comic books because of how accurate
it was to the character I don't know that there's
ever or at least not since Iron Man Downey Jr had
there been a comic book character change in the
comic books because of the actor and that is Ryan
reynolds's Deadpool for years they kept writing
Ryan Reynolds into Deadpool jokes because they
were trying to get this movie made there's a Joe
Oak in one of the early Deadpool comics saying
that the Wade Wilson looks like Ryan Reynolds
crossed with a radioactive Sharpay for years they
were trying to get this going but then after this
movie the character is written especially
the Jerry Duggan stuff the Brian passane
stuff it sounds like the Ryan Reynolds sensibility
because this is accurate to the comics because it
distilled so much Deadpool down into one perfect
thing this took 30 years of Deadpool comics and it
found his Beating Heart Deadpool is interesting
because he's one of the only Heroes that wears
a mask not to protect his identity but he's
protecting your stomach from his horrendous face
his his dignity his shame and his use of Comedy
as a defense mechanism were all found in this
one beautiful story where it's a story about love
it's a story about cancer it's a story about loss
but it's a goddamn superhero story with Quentin
Tarantino action set pieces and lots and lots
of Dick jokes this is a movie that means you can
watch a pegging sequence on Disney plus right now
that is more accurate that some of the comic books
were about the very same character and it changed
the comic books going forward Deadpool I think
is not just one of the most accurate comic book
adaptations but it's one of the most important and
I think when you look at R-rated superhero movies
that came out after Deadpool it owes them a lot
of thanks and I'm really excited and hopeful we'll
get to see something like that with Deadpool in
the MCU I think they will be as accurate as this
first one because of how much Kevin feige loves
the comics and because of Ryan Reynolds love for
this character but I'm really curious to see what
that looks like in a new world in this shared MCU
so keep it accurate keep it awesome Deadpool's
my number two and my number one is actually
probably gonna be a little shorter than some of
my rest because it just does all of the things
I've described and it mixes in really cool medium
choices in its flourish of black and white with
color and that is Sin City it uses the beautiful
Noir style of filmmaking that the comic books
resonate with and adds the color much like the
comics do but it does it in a way that it feels
like when you're reading a comic book and you're
letting your imagination go how you're flipping
between panels This captures that sometimes in
frame rate sometimes in an edit sometimes I an
acting choice but this truly feels like reading
a comic almost as much as into the spider-verse
does this is with live action actors the closest
thing I can describe to people that have never
enjoyed comic books you're in a world that is so
fleshed out every supporting character matters
just as much as the lead every lead is exactly who
they feel like on the pulpiness of the page you
can smell these frames and it's all authentically
Frank Miller it's all exactly what the book feels
like it's Ultra violent it's interesting it's
empathetic you care and still everyone's at an 11.
everyone is larger than life everyone is in the
world of Sin City just as Sin City changed comic
books Sin City changed movies and it is impossibly
accurate impossibly important and when people talk
about comic book movies sin city deserves some
respect on its name this really helped things
get going if blade gave us the MCU I think Sin
City gave us a lot of the adult oriented content
that we get now and uh yeah put some respect on
its name since the city's the tits alright let
me know what you think if you read comics and
you think there's an accurate comic book movie
I missed let me know if you disagree with my uh
world view on something being accurate by being
authentic to the character but different from the
comics let me know like you know your Deadpools
and such and most of all let me know what you're
enjoying reading a lot of you have been asking
for comic book recommendations for this video
I'm gonna say Deadpool The Good the Bad and the
Ugly if you want some sweet sweet Ryan Reynolds
earnesty with some Deadpool Dead Presidents if you
want that comedy the Jerry Duggan type comedy that
uh Rhett Reese and Paul Warnick do so very well
I would also recommend you read at least volume
one of Sin City that's my my passionate cry out
to understand what that world of Pulp is a lot of
people read comics and they think the younger side
but Pulp Comics especially adult Comics like Frank
Miller have a lot of beauty to them that doesn't
get discussed enough and then finally for my last
recommendation let's go with you know what [__]
it read me from vendetta a lot of people give a
lot of love to Watchmen as they should I do think
it's the most important comic book maybe ever made
but I don't feel like V for Vendetta gets enough
love and as we live in a world that uh these
conversations are discussed more often and as
these important elements of politics are bandied
about day to day I think a great palatable way to
discuss Big Brother Fascism and treason is V for
Vendetta get into it you lovelies uh that is gonna
do it for this episode please do like subscribe
hit that Bell so you find out when when the next
comic corner is I don't know where the Bell is
Greg told me it was down here I think and I've
always been pointing up here because I think of
bells as above but hit the bell and then be back
for more koi's comic Corner let me know in the
comments what else you want to see and tell Greg
you want a hundred greatest comic book movies
that's what you do all right see you next time